hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar spectroscopy
techniques for tomorrow's scientists
evolving technology for the teaching
laboratory
I'm Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by thermo Fisher
Scientific thermo Fisher is a world
leader in serving science whose mission
is to enable customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer for more
information on our sponsor please visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers
: seeing or hearing the presentation
just click on the support tab found at
the top-right of the presentation window
or report your problem by typing it into
the answer a question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker John Frost PhD
the product manager for thermo
scientific Pico spin NMR spectrometers
and thermo Fisher Scientific in Madison
Wisconsin he holds a PhD from the
University of Wisconsin in analytical
and physical chemistry where his work
contributed to multiple patents and a
master's degree in organic chemistry
from Michigan Technological University
with a deep commitment to the education
of the next generation of scientists dr.
frost has co-authored several papers in
the Journal of chemical education
served as adjunct faculty and actively
participates in multiple outreach
programs for high schools dr. frost will
begin his presentation
thank you for that kind introduction so
today's webinar is spectroscopy
techniques for tomorrow's scientists
evolving technology for the teaching
laboratory and we're going to briefly
review some of the most common
spectroscopic techniques in the chemical
sciences curriculum how they fit in the
curriculum
some examples of laboratories ways to
communicate the technique to your
students and a few examples of how
they're used in the real world it's
getting right into it we are all
familiar with the electromagnetic
spectrum and the fact that students are
typically exposed to three types of
spectroscopy in their high school and
undergraduate chemical careers
ultraviolet and visible spectroscopy
infrared spectroscopy and NMR
conveniently they're kind of arranged
from right to left in this particular
graphic as well and that's the way that
students typically encounter them
they'll in the high school and maybe
freshman chemistry neural chemistry
laboratories they'll experience visible
and potentially UV visible spectroscopy
when they get into that sophomore level
organic course they'll start to run into
FTIR and maybe be exposed to the basic
theory and interpretation of NMR
spectroscopy and then again in their
senior years either through P chem or a
senior level instrumentation class or in
graduate school will be exposed again to
these techniques and more of a hands-on
and at a more advanced level
so pirates summarize again the different
techniques and how they're different
they're used we've got UV visible and
we'll split that into the ultraviolet
portion and the visible portion
ultraviolet being from 50 to 400
nanometers although we too typically
work between 190 and 400 nanometers but
in either case we're working with fairly
high energy radiation which excite
valence electrons and it's typically
used to determine concentration there is
some qualitative measurements that can
be taken with these techniques but
typically we're simply measuring
concentration and we introduce visible
and UV visible in either the high school
or first-year undergrad courses infrared
as I said comes in that second year
undergrad this is a lower energy
radiation source and the infrared and
instead of exciting day linked electron
we're vibrating covalent bonds or just
looking at perturbing those just enough
to increase those oscillations and from
that we're getting functional group
information information about bond type
and from that we're starting to get a
lot more qualitative information about
the molecule itself and then we get to
NMR with radio frequencies extremely low
energies and we're perturbing the
nuclear spin States to learn more about
being that magnetic environment of the
nucleus and thereby get information on a
lot of qualitative information on the
molecule itself so the structure but
also concentration solvent temperature
and a number of other things I'm a
little biased because I hand them the
NMR product manager but I think there's
a lot of information there and we
typically introduce these this technique
to students in that second year
undergrad organic course but don't in
many cases allow them access to hands-on
use the instrument until at senior level
instrumentation course or even graduate
school so jumping in a little bit more
in-depth to UV visible spectroscopy
we're looking at the portion of the
spectrum between x-rays and infrared and
while the instruments themselves are
typically fairly
to operate it has great analytical the
results that are very accurate very
reproducible even at very low
concentration so it's a very useful
technique and we see it used in a lot of
different industries
when we introduce the concept from an
instrumentation side of things we show
them the white light source goes into
through them entrance slip to a
monochromator that splits that white
light into all this individual colors
and we use a exit slit to select a
single wavelength which is untranslated
through the sample to the detector and
we get our numerical readout from more
the conceptual standpoint we talked
about the ground state and with the
absorption of a photon of light if that
photon matches the energy level
difference between the ground state and
the excited state that electron will be
excited absorb that molecule for that
photon and be excited into the excited
state when that's the absorption and
that's really as far as we take it
before we we jump into beers law and
start talking about the practical
measurement of various components using
UV visible spectroscopy and so there's a
nice entry level lab where we look at
some third common food dyes determine
the peak absorbance for each of those
dyes and then build a calibration curve
using blue food dye which can then be
used to determine the concentration of
the dye in a commercial sports drink so
giving them a direct relevant relatable
link to the rest of their life when they
come back to it again at the senior
level we start thinking about not just
that simple transition from one
electronic state to the next
you know ground state to excited state
but we start looking at hey there's fine
structure within there you can actually
look at the individual vibratory nodes
within that energy level and so we can
look at the fine structure using a /
instrument with a little bit higher
resolution lower bandwidth and from
there we can start looking at perhaps
the bond disassociation energies for
various halogens so in this example you
would put a few crystals of iodine in
the bottom of 10
a ten-centimeter gas cell allow that to
sublimate and then you can measure the
affine electronic structure there
related to the individual vibratory
levels within that electronic energy
level and from that calculate out the
bond disassociation energy for these
various halogens from an instrumental
advancement point of view the technique
is very mature but there still progress
being made one of the biggest
advancements in recent history has been
the introduction of micro volume UV
vision measurements so instead of using
a once enemy cell or 1/2 centimeter cell
instead you can remove the cuvette
entirely and pipette 1 to 2 microliters
of sample directly on a pedestal now you
can kind of see in this upper right-hand
picture there's an arm that will then
come down make contact with that droplet
and then relax out to pull that droplet
into a liquid column and that column
acts as your measurement zone and with a
very precise measurement of the distance
between those two contact points you
have your path length and you just
transmit transmitted through via optical
fibers and take your measurement that
way so huge reduction in sample volume
requirements and that's open to not a
lot of new applications within the
technique
eliminating a lot of the
keep vets especially in the UV region
are quite expensive and just speaking up
and simplifying the process overall
so as an example where we might see this
used in advanced biochemistry laboratory
or even in industry we can look at
sample contaminant identification and in
this case we acquire our spectrum this
would be on a purified DNA sample and we
want to look at that spectrum and
identify is there potential contaminants
from the extractant
or from proteins that may have been
extract alongside it and we can look at
some different ratios of the absorbance
measurements at different wavelengths
and use some chemometric modeling to
analyze that data so hey there's
something going on here and then using
kinetics extract that to not only
determine what the contaminant is if
it's a protein contaminant or señal
which is a common extracting but then
also to correct the total absorbance for
the DNA so that we have a true DNA
concentration value rather than just the
combined from the DNA plus the various
contaminants and you know a way to bring
this back to the students is in addition
to folding this into the existing
software there's little training videos
and support pages built into the
software to give students that onboard
support refreshing armor and oh that's
that's what we're doing now this is this
is how this related
of a conventional sense heavy-metal
testing is very important we see that a
lot in industry so iron and water is
something that needs to be measured
according to EPA guidelines and so here
we'll do is reduce all the iron in a
water sample to iron to complex that
with financially and then that
red-orange solution can be measured
against calibration curve using some
external standards and to determine the
iron concentration so you don't need
atomic absorption in order to do this
measurement you simply complex the iron
to financial mean and then you can make
that measurement using visible
spectroscopy
on to the infrared portion of the
spectrum you can see we've shifted to
some lower energy and although the
infrared portion typically spans between
14,000 and 200 reciprocal centimeters we
typically for education perspective only
work between 4000 and 400 reciprocal
centimeters so we're we're looking at
the mid wavelength infrared group
frequency and fingerprint regions
here we already have bonds that are
naturally vibrating just through the
normal processes and what we need to do
is find a wavelength of light that will
be in resonance with that natural energy
of vibration and so as long as they're
vibrating we find that matching
resonance we then absorb a photon of
light that photon increases the
amplitude that vibration and we see the
absorption now one of the requirements
for this is that the molecule must have
a dipole moment so while they cannot be
ionic bonds we do need to have a more of
a polar covalent or at least somewhat
politically bond in order for this to
work so obviously we can do nonpolar
absorptions but a proton proton bond is
something we can't measure because there
is no dipole moment and so there's no
absorption possible so we don't see that
with nitrogen to either
kind of bring it back through different
model you can see again we're looking at
the energy diagram and we're looking at
individual vibratory energy levels
within that and those vibration levels
can be in a number of different planes
we can have anti-symmetric or symmetric
stretching scissoring wagging twisting
Rocking and this is great learning
opportunity for students to understand
not just you know the theory and this
two dimensional practical sense with the
math and things like that but also to
get a little movement into your
classroom as well something that was
very popular when I went through school
was the infrared spectra dance and you
can have their students practice these
anti symmetric stretching and symmetric
stretching using their arms and if you
really want to get fancy you can throw
in a third nucleus and now you've got a
leg involved and it gets quite humorous
quite quickly but it's a great way to
get the students to engage as the
material and really understand what
these these different transitions are
and how they all relate to each other
and these aren't simply just vibrations
for the sake of it they give us a great
deal of information about the structure
of the molecule itself so all of these
vibrations are very well understood it's
a very mature technique and so we can
relate CH stretches to aliphatic carbons
or to Co carbonyl stretches and all
sorts of different functional groups of
bond characteristics and this is well
known well-documented and you'll find
lots of tables online and charts we even
have a wheel that allows you to select
the wavelength or reciprocal centimeter
absorption and then look at all the
possible absorptions that that might be
associated with to relate that to that
structure from laboratory perspective
the synthesis of aspirin is a very
common one and one that will cook coming
back to in this presentation because of
its ubiquitous presence in the sophomore
organic chemistry lab and so here we've
got the salicylic acid being reacted
with acetic anhydride to form aspirin
and if we look at the infrared spectra
of the starting materials you see we
have a very strong o H phenol stretch
we've got that carbon carboxylic acid
absorption as well in a couple different
places and then we have the C double
bond o acetic anhydride Peaks as well
and then when we move to the product the
C the salicylic acid you see there is no
phenyl hydroxyl group and we've lost
that same stretch same thing with the
acetic anhydride Peaks have gone away
and instead we've formed that ester
that's Co ester so it's pretty clear and
the students can look at this related to
their tabulated data and justify their
conclusion that the reaction was indeed
successful by analyzing these individual
spectra and inspector of the funding
program
similarly wintergreen oil gives a very
pleasant odor in the laboratory can be
you start with salicylic acid that same
starting material but in this case
reacted with methanol so we've got that
very distinctive broad strong hydroxyl
stretch out of the 32 3300 and with the
formation again of the wintergreen the
methyl salicylate that hydroxyl group is
gone and so we we lose that big broad
stretch and we also lose the carboxylic
acids as well in favor of the ester so
the analysis of the two is very similar
from a
mental perspective one of the biggest
advancements is the introduction of
attenuated total reflectance as a way to
sample your measurements in many cases
gone are the days of KBR pellets or salt
plates and instead what we're using is
attenuated total reflectance and how
this works is a beam of light is
injected into the crystal at a
particular angle at which point it will
undergo a process called attenuated
total internal reflectance at the point
of total internal reflections 100
percent of the input light is reflected
out there's no loss of the light
intensity due to reflectance and so you
get 100% transmission out the other side
of the crystal
however the physics shows that at that
point of total internal reflections you
will form an evanescent wave and that
evidence and wave is shown by these
small increasingly gray triangles that
extend up and what those are those are
evanescent waves that extend out beyond
the point of total internal reflections
but don't detract from it in and of
themselves they do however have the
ability to interact with a neighboring
substance and couple light into that for
absorption purposes so if you have a
sample in contact with that crystal and
it needs to be in contact so as all
these 80 RS you'll see a little arm that
comes down and compresses the sample
down because the evanescent wave only
extends a fraction of a wavelength into
the sample but so these are surface
level measurements but when it is in
contact with that point then the
evanescent wave will couple light into
the material and you will allow
absorption to occur
with any out any direct interaction
between the light itself and the sample
which is pretty interesting stuff but it
really simplifies getting your students
through a given lab quickly and moving
moving things along once we get into
advanced 3 we start talking about
michael ranson interferometer
interferometry and using fast Fourier
transform in order to convert that time
domain spectra into a frequency domain
or time domain interferogram into a
frequency domain spectrum and then the
difference between the transmittance and
the absorption spectrum and working with
both of those in an industrial setting
we we CFT are used in many different
industries it's a very useful technique
that pops up almost everywhere but one
of the big ones lately has been for the
rapid detection of phthalates and we
worry about phalates
in tumour products and especially when
it comes to baby and small children's
toys we want to keep salads out of there
and FDA are especially with ATR is very
useful as a fast screening tool so you
simply need to put the material in
question in contact with that ATR
crystal press down on the little arm and
very quickly you'll be able to identify
the presence of salads the ortho
automatic group has a strong absorbance
and around 741 to 745 and then they also
have characteristic doublets at 1600 and
1580 from the aromatic ring stretching
and so if we look at
spectrum this plastic that in this case
does have satellites in it we see very
characteristically that's 745 and the
doublet there at 1580 to 1600 and so
very quickly within a matter of seconds
we could say yes the sample does in fact
contain valleys all right moving on to
my favorite nuclear magnetic resonance
we're pushing all the way past
ultraviolet visible infrared and now
we're into the radio spectrum so this is
FM broadcast range between one megahertz
and one gigahertz it's about 300 meter
to 30 centimeters but we're also
covering the high frequency very high
frequency and ultra high frequency so
the VHF and uhf that some some of us may
remember from the old televisions we had
to select the different channels by hand
but if we look at the NMR spectrum and
NMR Theory here we're not looking at
high-energy mall radiation we're looking
very very low energy radio frequency and
what we're doing is we're looking at the
nucleus of the atom itself and I'm going
to try to split this into what we see
taut typically at the high school and
organic sophomore level versus what
would we see beyond so you'll get a
little bit of theory of both but we
won't dive too deep
in either case so what we're looking at
is we're looking at the nucleus rather
than valence electrons or vibrations as
we are with the other ones instead we're
looking at the nucleus itself and so if
we consider hydrogen which is where we
do most NMR from a technique standpoint
we're looking at the proton so proton
has a charge it also has a nuclear spin
state associated with it if you have a
spinning charge you have a particle that
will behave like a small magnet and
these magnetic moments are oriented
randomly in space in kind of a ground
state situation but it
we then introduce a outside field a
magnetic field they are forced to either
adopt an orientation with that external
field which is the lower energy state or
against that field which is the higher
energy state now we have two different
energy states just as we do with UV vis
and that allows us to have a Boltzmann
population distribution and therefore to
do some spectroscopy and and talking
about the two different energy states
and the relationship of that to field
strength and the size of the magnet is
oftentimes where we stop the theoretical
discussion of NMR at that entry level
when we come back to it we start to
think well well how do we actually
record the measurement and that's that's
where it really gets interesting so if
we have these new clean dividual nuclei
and they're the majority of them are in
the lower energy state and so they are
oriented with the external field and
what we call the z axis if we kind of
sum them all up they're all pointing on
average we get one magnetic moment that
is our magnetic field vector that's
straight along the z axis now these are
are not pointing straight up just as a
top wobble so these wobble - with a
characteristic frequency and but if we
average everything together we get one
magnetic field vector straight up along
the z axis if we bring in a
radiofrequency coil and we transmit at
the frequency that these individual
protons are naturally processing called
the larmor precession frequency we then
cause them to decode and phase coherence
so they're all tipped to the same
direction at the same time and that
causes a shift in the magnetic field
vector into the XY plane at that point
we can turn off the transmitter and
allow those nuclei to relax back to the
z axis and ozone what you could consider
their their ground state and so what
we're doing there is we're looking at
their free Lac free relaxation or decay
back
that ground state and we're doing so as
they induce a charge because remember
we're looking at these nuclei as if they
were small little magnets and whenever
you have a magnet that's moving inside a
coil its inducing a chart of current in
that coil and so we call it the free
induction decay so it's the free decay
back to the z axis and as a result we're
inducing that current and that causes
the F ID that is unique to each each
proton under observation now if we look
at it something like ethanol we've got
three chemically distinct types of
hydrogen so we've got the three
hydrogen's attached to the methyl group
two to the methylene and then one on
that hydroxyl they all have their unique
characteristic frequency and will result
in our own F ID those all get piled on
top of each other during the measurement
however and so we get some very
interesting squiggly lines which through
the same Fourier transform process that
we used in infrared we can use to
transform it from the time domain into
the frequency domain and we get it
individual unique signal for each of the
three hydrogen types and a jumping back
to what we introduced at the entry level
in that organic chemistry class we spend
most of our time talking about how to
interpret the spectrum so just like we
spend a lot of time teaching
interpretation of the infrared spectrum
and the organic chemistry level we do
the same thing that's where we provide
our focus for NMR as well we talk about
how many signals and how those relate to
the individual hydrogen's and
multiplicity and that's how an
individual signal may split into more
than one peak so if we look over towards
the right and see a group of three Peaks
that's referred to as a triplet and
that's one signal but it is three Peaks
each of the distinct energy and then we
look at the integration and how that's
inherently quantitative and can give us
information not just about how many
hydrogens make up that signal but
also if there are mixtures and how we
can use that to pull out quantitative
information about the sample
gentle perspective the major advances
here than the instrument itself for many
years
NMR instruments were large floor-mounted
units the smallest of which weighed in
at over 800 pounds and in tooth light
2011 the Pico spent 45 was introduced
weighing in only 10 and a half pounds at
445 megahertz fast Fourier transform
instrument meant that students at
smaller four-year universities community
colleges and even high schools would no
longer have to rely on photocopied NMR
that were distributed to their students
at the end of the lab or you know for
those universities that did have a high
shield system available no board grad
students having to collect everyone
samples and then run them overnight
either manually or with an autosampler
instead students had the ability to
bring the technique right in to the lab
write on the badge top and run the
experiment themselves and see how their
sample turned out not how a generic one
in ways that we've introduced this
various levels you know because the
instruments were so large and expensive
in the past it was really a
closely-guarded
technique but we've seen it grow in
popularity and be introduced to students
of all levels and so we've seen a lot of
development in how the technique is
introduced to students even at the high
school level and that multiplicity I was
talking about before can be very easily
used to demonstrate to students quantum
mechanics we talked about quantum
mechanics for the first time in high
school level chemistry classes because
it's so important to everything we do in
chemistry and physics but there's really
very few ways to show students that
quantum mechanics is anything more than
a mathematical trick that some super
smart physicists played with and in the
nineteen hundreds but we can show that
to them and we can relate it to them
very easily you can think of yourself
and your own mood and relate that to a
neighbor and if you have one neighbor
and that neighbor
happy and you are happy that's one
relationship with one combined energy if
you're happy and they're not so happy
and grumpy that day that's a different
that will affect you in a different way
and lead to a different energies your
combined state so if you have one
neighbor you have two possible
orientations you're happy and they're
happy you're happy in they're sad and so
you get two different energies you get
two different peaks and we see that in
the upper right hand corner you see we
have a signal single signal under
interest but it splits into two
different peaks because of the effect of
that neighboring quantum spin and you
can extend that beyond the two neighbors
or four neighbors or however many
neighbors you'd like and you can add
levels of difficulty by having the
students calculate the change in energy
of the spin states using the J couplings
and you can extrapolate that as far as
you'd like we've had professors
extrapolate this simple demo all the
weight into a graduate-level quantum
mechanics experiment for physics
graduate students using Hamiltonian and
calculating all sorts of things so it's
a really versatile little tool to
introduce and show students one of these
basic concepts is is more than just
academic hyperbole another concept that
comes up in every general chemistry
course is percent composition so you can
look at some very simple solutions of
rubbing alcohol or vinegar in water and
in that those cases you can collect
multiplicity and everything about the
NMR itself and just focus on letting the
students warm up to the use of
instrumentation realize that there are
other ways to measure things that are
colorless and so may not have a visible
absorption and so we can just ignore the
multiplicity of the NMR spectrum focus
on the integration and use those
relative integration ratios to calculate
concentration in a number of different
ways and
molar concentration percent by weight
percent by volume and things like that
course at this point I have to bring
back the synthesis of aspirin or
wintergreen oils to bring everything
together and so salicylic acids
subjected to certification to produce
either one of those you end up with two
very different NMR spectra and you have
all the multiplicity and J couplings you
need to pull out each of the individual
often substituted aromatic ring portions
and look at the effect of that that acid
and where it shows up and kind of relate
these to the spectral interpretation
that students are expected to learn at
that organic chemistry level an advanced
level or an industrial setting
you see NMR used in a variety of
different ways for reaction monitoring
and all sorts of things but one we see a
lot in industry is determining the
molecular weight of polymers so polymers
start with these simple chains and then
they're reacted through process which
causes them to grow and grow but
determining the average molecular weight
of that composition is something that
manufacturers work with because it
determines a lot of that polymers
characteristics and so they need to
figure this out and NMR is one of the
preferred techniques and it's related
directly to the percent composition lab
in terms of the mathematics is very
similar again we're kind of ignoring the
multiplicity we're ignoring individual
resonances and we're focusing on well
here we've got one area we know is
related to this we've got another area
Reno is related to that and we can look
at these ratios and and combine that
with the other information we know about
the starting material and determine
things like the molecular weight the
composition the hydroxyl number all of
these things that determine a polymers
physical characteristics and are very
important in their daily lives but
without all the fancy math that we
sometimes see in interpretation of small
molecules
so with that I would thank you for your
time and encourage anyone looking for
more information to visit our chemistry
in the classroom webpage or you can view
more information on the labs we have
available we have a number of different
laboratories you can incorporate into
your classroom and you can also learn
more information about our Nicolay
Summit FTIR spectrometer our Pico spent
80 and Pecos 1045 series 2 NMR
spectrometers and our Genesis line of UV
visible spectrometer
if there's any questions I'd be happy to
answer them thank you dr. frost for your
presentation so a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. frost will answer as many questions
as time permits the first question is
how can I get all my students through
the laboratory collecting data on their
sample and processing the data
right we'll let depend on your number of
students in your classroom and the
number of instrumentations of the
instruments available but we haven't
designed all of our instruments to be
classroom friendly and really focus on
throughput and so we have things like
our onic anywhere and the thermo
official cloud that allows data to be
directly uploaded to a network drive or
a cloud storage drive and that allows
students then to process that offline so
they can go up use the instrument but do
processing away from the instrument so
that the next student can come and get
their sample analyzed as well keep
things moving quickly and usually thank
you next one is what is the difference
between your more affordable
spectrophotometers and your advanced
models
that's a great question really with all
of our instruments the difference
between the more affordable options and
the more advanced instruments really
comes down to specifications and the
ability to adapt to new exams and new
applications so with the more affordable
instruments you have kind of a larger
specification windows and not a lot of
accessories that are able to adapt to
them once you get to the upper level
models you have tighter specs better
performance and a lot more accessories
that allow you to adapt a given
instrument to take a number of different
measurements in a number of different
ways so maybe their temperature
controlled cell holders fibre probes
ATRs or just better performance and
reaction monitoring accessories all
sorts of different accessories start to
playing the game that allows you to kind
of take it from a simple bench mounted
and one at a time measurement to more
automated measurement or a more focused
measurement for this particular
application that I can then transition
later to do a different measurement
somewhere else thank you the next one is
have you had many high schools use your
instrumentation yes we have we've had a
number of instruments you notice respect
200 is a staple within the high school
market but Genesis is taking off as well
and then within you know with the high
schools that offer AP and IB classes
there's been some changes in the rules
that have encouraged more use of
hands-on instrumentation so we're seeing
a lot more infrared and even NMR being
adopted by high schools
thank you what other industries are
spectrophotometers commonly used in
spectrometers are used all over the
place
we see them in pharmaceutical industry
Palmer's batteries energy storage solar
energy thin films plastics Patrick M
food testing hospitals life sciences
it is spectroscopy is the way we use
light which is you know one of the most
available sources of energy we have to
measure the world around us so we use it
all the time pretty much everywhere we
need to make a chemical measurement will
in some way shape or form turn to
spectroscopy so it you'll find it just
about everywhere
thank you looks like we have time for
one more question what kinds of warranty
and maintenance are associated with
these instruments
so all of our instruments as I said were
designed both with industrial
applications in mind but also with an
eye towards our educational partners and
how they might be used in the classroom
so we've taken steps to make sure that
our instruments are very durable and as
a result we've been on able to offer
industry-leading warranties on all of
our instruments so those industries
range from two to ten years I believe
and your sales representative would
certainly be able to talk to you more
about that but from a maintenance
perspective they're all very lonely as I
would probably argue FTIR is maybe the
the most maintenance intensive and in
that case you really only need to change
desiccants every few years of the most
so yeah so maybe desiccants were one
point during life for the instrument but
beyond that all of our our instruments
is on to the classroom our intended to
just be plugged in and used and be
really robust I remember a few years ago
a few of our sales reps were really
advocating for us to drive over some of
our spectrometers with the truck because
they believed that they would still work
on the other side of them so they're
they're very very durable require very
little maintenance and are back as a
result are backed by some very strong
warranties I would like to once again
thank dr. frost for his presentation do
you have any final comments
just thanks again everyone for taking
time today if you have any additional
questions feel free to reach out to me
or through the email link provided you
have your questions answered directly by
myself for the the appropriate technique
expert
thank you again and I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsors Thermo Fisher
Scientific underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through October 20 19
lab routes will alert you via email and
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye